,
AND PROFOUND.
AS WE TOLD YOU A MINUTE AGO, THE
OTHER THING THAT HAPPENED,
THAT'S KIND OF GREAT, THAT WE'RE
ENJOYING, THE GUY IN CHARGE OF
GETTING DEMOCRATS ELECTED TO
CONGRESS LOST.
HIS NAME IS SEAN PATRICK
MALONEY, REPRESENTING THE HUDSON
VALLEY, BEATEN BY THE
CONGRESSMAN ELECT.
HE JOINS US.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
HOW DID YOU DO THIS?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, TUCKER.
WELL, LOOK, DEMOCRATS CONTROL
EVERYTHING THIS WITH WASHINGTON,
ALBANY, AND NEW YORK CITY FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY, AND CREATED AN ABSOLUTE
MESS.
A 41-YEAR RECORD HIGH INFLATION,
SURGING CRIME, SKYROCKETING
ENERGY COSTS, AND A POROUS
SOUTHERN BORDER, WITH A MASSIVE
INFLOW OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
BUT DRUGS COMING INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES, KILLING 300
AMERICANS A DAY.
VOTERS IN NEW YORK WERE FED UP.
THEY HAD ENOUGH.
THEY WANTED TO RESTORE BALANCE
AND COMMON SENSE TO EVERY LEVEL
OF GOVERNMENT.
WE'VE PICKED UP FOUR
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS IN NEW YORK.
WE'LL HAVE 11 OF NEW YORK'S 26
MEMBERS AS REPUBLICANS COME
JANUARY.
THAT IS HISTORIC.
I THINK IN MY DISTRICT
ESPECIALLY, YOU KNOW, SEAN
WANTED TOKNOCK REPUBLICANS DOWNE
SEATS.
THEY DID IT.
THE COURTS INTERVENED.
A DEMOCRAT-APPOINTED COURT OF
APPEALS, THREW OUT THE MESS,
CALLED ITGEREY MANNEDDERRED AND
UNCONSTITUTION, AND APPOINTED A
SPECIAL MASTER.
WE GOT A MAP.
WHEN I LOOKED AT THE MAP, I KNEW
I COULD WIN THE SEAT.
42% IS FROM THE COUNTY WHERE I'M
BORN AND RAISED.
I'VE LIVED HERE MY ENTIRE LEAVE.
WE WON ROCKLAND I BY 10 POINTS.
THAT'S WHY I DEFEATED SEAN
PATRICK MALONEY YESTERDAY.
>> Tucker: PROBABLY NOT ENOUGH
VICTORIES TO CELEBRATE, BUT THE
ONES THAT CAME THROUGH ARE WORTH
CELEBRATING.
THIS IS SPECIAL AMAZING, BECAUSE
HE'S THE CHARGE OF GETTING
DEMOCRATS ELECTED TO CONGRESS.
DO YOU THINK HE SAW IT COMING?
>> NO, NOT REALLY, BECAUSE HE
WAS GALAVANTING ACROSS THE GLOBE
TO PARIS, GENEVA AND LONDON JAYS
MONTH AGO RAISING MONEY FOR
NANCY PELOSI.
ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO HE REALIZED
HE HAD A PROBLEM WHEN HE HAD TO
CALL IN BILL CLINTON TO COME
CAMPAIGN.
HE ASKED HILLARY CLINTON TO SEND
AN EMAIL, NOT THE 30,000 THAT
SHE DELETED, BUT HE ALSO ASKED
JOE BIDEN TO COME IN AND DO A
FUNDRAISER FOR HIM JUST LAST
WEEK.
YOU KNOW, THIS DISTRICT IS HOME
TO THE CLINTONS AND GEORGE
SOROS.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY NOW HAVE
A REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN SPEAKS
VOLUMES TO WHERE THE ELECTORATE
IS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S PRETTY GREAT.
REALLY IS.
WE'RE GOING TO CELEBRATE.
CONGRESSMAN ELECT MIKE